so here in the UK we are coming up to
exam season and over the next four or
five weeks people are going to be taking
their GCSEs and their a levels so I
thought this would be an excellent
opportunity to do just a quick video
series getting you ready for those exams
now this video we're gonna be talking
about revision techniques and revision
strategies where its next video we're
going to be talking about exam technique
and then after that we'll be a quick
video hopefully providing you with just
a little motivation boost to keep going
for the last difficult days the first
thing I want to emphasize in this video
is that there are lots of other video
resources out there notably I have a
video which I uploaded a few years ago
now on how to study effectively really
that shaming called how to revise
effectively because that's that's really
what it is but that contains all the
information that I can offer you on how
to be effective in using your time now
there are other videos out there there's
a little app in the description by the
way and there's also links in
description to videos by my friend Jamie
who is another Oxford graduate and my
friends Jake who's a current Cambridge
student who have both done similar
videos go away and watch those and
they'll provide you with a good tool kit
that we're going to be referring to in
this video the key point which I make in
my video is that there is no substitute
for hard work and the best way to ensure
you will do well on a test is to revise
for a long time and to work hard now we
are a month away from these exams so if
you haven't started revising yet get on
it as soon as this video is over get on
it and it's still possible to do well if
you use that time effective do still
very possible to do well so there's no
cause to panic the first point I want to
make in this video is to practice it's
something which I actually say in my own
house study effective video but the most
effective way to get ready for an exam
is to do that exam as many times as
possible in the form of past papers so
if you're not already doing them now
isn't great opportunity to start about a
month is the right length of time I
think let's pray about the minimum
length of time that you want to be
really gunning through exam pass papers
if your school's not giving them to you
then they are more often not available
online in great numbers make sure that
you have the correct example and make
sure you're also aware of any changes to
the syllabus which may have happened
over the course of the exam papers being
available but crank through them just
get through as many as you can because
that is the most effective way to
prepare for an exam given the way that
our education system works really if you
are aware of what's on the page
burn you aware of what's the mark scheme
will reward you for you can't go too far
wrong that's the other tip of course is
to make sure you download the Mart
scheme if it's available and look at it
after you've done the paper so over the
course of several papers you're going to
be trending towards what the mark schema
is expecting of you in your answers but
just to emphasize again practice is key
get through as many past papers as you
possibly can the second point I want to
make and it's another one which I make
in my house study of interview video but
it is so important now take a care of
yourself you are currently like an
athlete preparing for a track meet or a
footballer preparing for a match the
difference is you are not getting your
body to peak physical performance you're
getting your mind to peak physical
performance and the only way to do that
is to take good care of yourself
particularly you've got to get enough
sleep so aim to be in asleep before
midnight and that might come as a shock
to some people because you're like
staying up on Facebook and playing
Minecraft I am guilty of that but you've
got to get in bed and get a good number
of hours sleep every night between now
and the exams no staying up all night
revising regards do you think it's going
to help it will probably do more harm
than good take a good care of yourself
get enough sleep I have a good diet make
sure you get some exercise now is the
most important time actually to do
exercise so if you play football go and
play with some friends if you go to the
gym go there just it's so important to
vent off some stress and some steam
about these exams because you can get so
wound up in it that you lose perspective
so take good care of yourself because no
one's going to do this exam but you and
you've got to be in the best condition
possible in order to do your best the
last point that I want to make in this
video is discipline it's kind of Now or
Never when it comes to your exams you
have four or five weeks left until you
sit down an example and write things on
a piece of paper and few weeks after
that you're going to be graded based on
what you said now there's no way that
you can affect the outcome of that grade
after you taking the exam the only way
you're going to improve it is by working
before the exam in other words between
now and four or five weeks time now is
when it really counts and now is when
you've got a really knuckle down to it
and it sucks revision is not really the
most enjoyable thing to do in the world
but now is the only opportunity you're
going to have to
have an impact on a grade which is going
to stay with you for the next few years
and impact the rest of your educational
trajectory so knuckle down to it you've
got to be disciplined about it work hard
now and you'll be rewarded in the future
so you've got just over a month left
into your exams so it's time to get down
to it do lots and lots of practice
work hard take good care of yourself and
you are going to seriously thank
yourself for doing that in the future
next week we're gonna be talking about
exam technique and really honing the
skills that you're going to be using in
the exam to make sure that all this work
now counsel the most possible when you
sit down and take your tests so if you
like the sound of that then please stick
around on this channel subscribe if you
like and if you found this video useful
then please consider giving it a like or
commenting below if you have any further
advice thanks for watching and I'll see
you next week